yesterday was election day in a few
states around the country it was not a
good day for Republicans this should
come as no surpris as Republicans
haven't had a good day on Election Day
since uh 2018 it's been loss after loss
after loss since then last night
Republicans lost the governor's race in
Kentucky they lost the State House of
Virginia and the most troubling result
of all they lost on a ballot initiative
in Ohio that has now enshrined child
sacrifice as a constitutional right
reading from the daily wire quote voters
in Ohio voted Tuesday to approve a
ballot initiative that places a right to
an abortion into the state's
Constitution PR Advocates say the
measure will effectively make AB
abortion legal at any point in pregnancy
the initiative brought in millions in
spending with more than $18 million
being spent in favor of the pro-abortion
initiative with just 7 million being
spent in opposition since October uh
since August 9th according to NBC News
the effort to put abortion into the
state constitution was backed by the
Ohio Democratic party the ACLU of Ohio
Planned Parenthood uh and Ohio's Women's
Alliance Martin hasell a proponent
proponent of partial birth abortion gave
gave $100,000 to Ohio Physicians for
Reproductive Rights a political action
committee that opposed a republican back
measure that would have made it more
difficult to amend the state
constitution has advocated for passage
of issue one prominent Ohio Republicans
like Governor Mike dwine and Senator JD
Vance spoke out against enshrining
abortion into the state's Constitution
calling the measure extreme now this
victory for baby murder was of course
cause for celebration in the media and
among child sacrifice enthusiasts Across
the Nation in Ohio they applauded and
cheered and embraced with tears of joy
in their eyes
watch abortion is
[Applause]
Healthcare and abortion access is the
law of the land in Ohio tonight Ohioans
United for Reproductive Rights passed
issue one and put Ohioans back in charge
of their decisions about pregnancy and
abortion together we successfully
enshrined the right to reproductive
Freedom into the Ohio Constitution
[Applause]
just imagine reacting that way to the
news that children in the womb just lost
all of their human rights because that's
what the that's what this Constitutional
Amendment does it it it says that
children in the womb have no rights at
all um if you are not yourself a
bloodthirsty sociopath it is impossible
to fully imagine reacting this way which
is why if you're like me when you see
them joyously celebrating the Mass
Slaughter of children you become more
resoled D than ever to fight and defeat
these people but if you're like many
milk toast Republicans you become more
resolved than ever to cower and
compromise and give these people
whatever they want in hopes that they
will have mercy on you and that has
essentially been the analysis from a
great many alleged conservatives since
last night and before that uh they have
determined that Not only was the result
in Ohio an indictment of the pro-life
message but that the other results were
also indictments of the pro-life message
in fact these Republicans insist that
every Republican defeat in every recent
election is because of abortion we must
abandon the issue or compromise
significantly on it in order to have any
chance of winning they say according to
this conventional right-wing wisdom the
overturning of row in the Supreme Court
was not a great victory for human rights
but was in fact a political disaster
that is solely to blame for all of the
losing the Republicans have been doing
the fact that this Republican track
record of losing stretches back before
dos the fact that they have been getting
wiped out since before The Supreme Court
issued any decision on this topic has
apparently occurred to these people or
it has but they find it convenient to
blame Pro lifers anyway if you turned on
Fox news last night and I'm not sure why
you would ever want to do such a thing
uh you you would have heard a lot of
this kind of capitulating and blame
shifting here's just a short Taste of
itats are trying to scare women into
thinking Republicans don't want abortion
legal under any
circumstances and I go back to
Pennsylvania
2022 the Republican candidate for
governor if I remember correctly no
exceptions for rape incest of the
mother's life and lost to a
non-incumbent uh gubernatorial candidate
Democratic candidate uh by a margin that
was not seen since the
1940s so I have to believe that is an
indication that the women in America
Suburban moms want it probably legal and
rare and probably earlier than you know
at the point of viability how do they
stop bumbling on abortion what's the
answer well number one well the
Republicans have to clear up this issue
across these states with clear lines
like a 15 to 20 week abortion ban with
exceptions for life incest uh and rape
and and make it clear you look at states
where that is sat in stone and we don't
have these problems we don't have these
problems in Florida we don't have these
problems in Georgia we don't have these
problems in North Carolina and part of
that is is because of that particular
issue so that's Sean Hannity and Rin
prus talking about how Republicans can
start winning now you may ask yourself
what in God's name do these two know
about winning what wins do they have
under their belt in what way has either
of them ever in their entire careers
helped conservatism win
anything serious question what have they
ever done what victory have they ever
achieved what ideological battles have
they fought and won in their
lives what ological battles have they
fought at all why the hell would anyone
come to them for insight on this issue
or any other these are all very good
questions but unfortunately they uh they
are not alone Republicans are
losing because of the abortion issue the
issue is unwinable pro-lifers are
screwing everything up and we must come
out and endorse legalize abortion in
order to win that is the message uh uh
from from many I mean you heard Hannity
say it abortion should be safe legal and
rare
that's what he said he's literally
repeating pro-abortion talking points
from the 90s he's a 1990s Clinton era
Democrat which is not exactly breaking
news I suppose but just to be clear if
you are a supposed conservative now
saying that we should embrace legalized
abortion that safe legal and rare should
be our Mantra then you are make no
mistake advocating for a fullscale
surrender on one of the most pivotal
fundamental issues of our time you're
free to take that position but please
for the love of God don't pretend to be
a fighter if you do you're waving the
White Flag you're doing the thing the
left never does and Republicans always
do but before you hoist that flag let me
offer a few thoughts a few
counterarguments to the Sha hannes of
the world first of all you can blame Pro
lifers for the uh for the Republican
party's string of electoral defeats or
again especially given that this string
of defeats began before dobs you can
consider instead the possibility that
Republicans by and large have been
running bad candidates and bad campaigns
this especially worth considering given
that many of the Republican losers over
the past few years have not exactly been
pro-life hardliners in plenty of cases
they've been essentially pro-abortion Dr
Oz Oz lost in Pennsylvania I mean we
heard we heard uh Hannity blame the the
the loss to the in the governor governor
race uh because supposedly the person
was a Hardline Pro prolifer Dr Oz
liberal on the issue in Pennsylvania and
he lost so how does that work with your
equation Sean
second the claim that conservatives
should moderate on abortion is not some
brilliant new insight okay I love all
these people acting like they just came
up with this you know I've just been
thinking about it and I think that this
this is not some bold political
Innovation this is what the Republican
establishment has been saying for my
entire life since I was born and before
the Republican establishment has
insisted that that the only way to win
is to go soft on abortion compromise
hide from the issue under sell it this
has been the conventional milk toast
Republican wisdom
forever does it appear to have been
effective does it have an actual track
record of success ask yourself that the
Republican esta establishment has been
losing and scapegoating social
conservatives forever they have been
blaming us for their their failures
since always this is nothing
new why would you buy into it now the
truth is that social conservatives are
the only ones on the right who have been
doing anything or winning anything
recently not only are we not to blame
for Republican losses but we are the
only ones who can claim any wins in the
last few years especially who else has
done anything
anybody hardcore social conservatives
know how to fight the culture war in
fact we're the only ones on the right
who
do third uh this is most important
before you tell me that the pro-life
message is a political loser answer me
this how many Republican candidates
fought back hard and effectively on this
issue actively went after the left ran
ads attacking their opponents for
supporting the dismemberment of fully
developed infants which nearly every
Democrat does and actually countered The
left's pro-abortion Narrative with a
strong and affirmative pro-life
narrative how many did that see this is
the problem the pro-life message is
being blamed in races where the pro life
message was never even articulated it's
being blamed for losing when there was
never any
Fight Pro aborts in Ohio outspent the
other side nearly 3 to one since August
and that's emblematic of the situation
across the country our side is is um you
know uh Pro
lifers are fighting Republicans are not
putting up a
fight so that doesn't mean we can't win
but it does mean we won't win if we
don't even
try consider this has any Republican
anywhere run an ad saying essentially
here's what happens in a third trimester
abortion my opponent supports this this
is the most basic strategy and I'm not
I'm not aware of anyone who's even
attempted it now I'm not saying that
they should show an abortion in an ad
because nobody would run it if they do
and you need people to run it but they
can describe what the procedure involves
okay there's a way to get this message
across and it's just very and people
don't know this okay a lot of people
don't know this they don't really know
what they're talking about when it comes
to this issue they don't know what this
issue is they don't understand and so
has there been anyone who's run an ad
saying look here's what this is here's
what this guy over here is running
against me here's he supports this um
and so if you agree with him then vote
for him you know what if you agree with
him on that I don't even want your vote
um but if you're a decent person then
then
then I I think you need you know what
you need to do the point is to go on
offense to flip the script to flip the
conversation focus it on the horrors and
barbarity of abortion and the abortion
industry this has not really been done
it has not really been attempted most of
the losing candidates have not done this
they have hid from the issue instead of
going on offense which is of course the
Republican
specialty you know Democrats want to
spend their entire time talking about
the hard cases rape incest life the
mother the cases that account for fewer
than 1% of all
abortions they focus the the whole
conversation on that Republicans allow
themselves to get baited into focusing
the conversation there where Democrats
want to focus it rarely have they
responded by saying we're not going to
talk about the 1% of cases until you
answer some questions about the 99%
here's what abortion is here's why 99%
of abortions are performed
here's what happens in most of these
abortions here's what happens in a third
trimester
abortion you need to answer for that
before we talk about anything else we're
not going to even talk about the 1%
until you talk about the
99 that should that should be the Mantra
not safe legal and
rare no the Mantra is we're not going to
let you people dictate this conversation
we're not going let you hide from from
from the difficult questions that you
need to answer
now very few Republicans have had the
balls or wherewithal or intelligence to
respond that way and so they
lose now the truth is for me I wouldn't
compromise on abortion even if it really
did mean losing every election from now
to Kingdom Come to accept child murder
is to forfeit your soul if we are really
a country if it is true that we are now
a country where child murder is so
fundamentally popular that it's
impossible to win by opposing
it then we are not a country worth
saving
anymore then who cares about this
country why are we even trying to save
it you're telling me that that if if
that that's the country that's like
fundamentally grounded in the slaughter
of
children where that's that you know
where that's as popular as apple
pie and that's the country we're
fighting for no we deserve whatever
destruction is coming our way in that
case I will never accept abortion I will
never compromise on it I would rather
die that's where I
stand but the good news is that the
whole premise is
flawed it's not I don't I don't believe
that it's
true that this country as a
whole is so enamored with
abortion okay I don't believe that it's
true that we are in fact a country of
baby killers there are some baby killers
in this
country I don't think they're the
majority
the pro-life message can win in this
country but only if we have the courage
to fight for it and the intelligence to
fight
well that's where Republicans tend to
fail both in the courage and the
intelligence
departments and that is why they
lose and that is why those Republicans
are today
cancelled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast